I'm Gloria Borger and you're watching
few news
[Music]
good evening I'm Gloria Borger today we
have a lot of news to discuss so let's
just stop anyway our first story comes
from John Edie
luckily as we reported last week Johnny
D was hospitalized because he suffered
from no Meah
but no nouméa pneumonia johnny is now
back he's looking better and he made a
response video they do not choose to
show yourself on YouTube like I do
they're very good I wish I was citizen
if you come to my town I'll show you
where to go I'll show you we can see the
best rappers the best things in this
city he will show you if you're in his
town Johnny D invites you to show his
favorite rapper it's wonderful to see
first of all how much support you guys
sent to the GoFundMe page it hit the
goal $15,000 an amazing effort good job
everyone I'm really proud to see how
empathetic and heartwarming and this
community of Squad fam can be and it's
really nice to see Johnny D just
genuinely being grateful in return next
news this week a female empowerment
movement was announced and it's called
bully hunters and as soon as I heard
about bully hunter initiative I thought
to myself there is just no way this
could go wrong whatsoever this is not
gonna end up like another train wreck
how is this real 2018 is is wonderful it
just keeps on giving so the idea behind
bully hunters is that to stop harassment
in games has been specifically Counter
Strike our C's go you can call upon a
bully hunter that will then join your
game and kill the bully in the game they
display this in the most hilariously
awkward and most scripted way I've ever
seen
now our bully hunter is as
the rose thorn live in game who is
harassing her and our victim then
immediately replied let's zoom in again
on the bottom left-hand corner now you
see there the tool connected these two a
victim with a bully hunter okay so now
bully hunter 77 knows the name of the
harasser and she is ready to take action
now we are going to switch over to bully
hunter 77 screen to watch the hunt cuz
of that feed please and play it so we
are watching our bully hunter she knows
who the harasser is and she's on the
hunt you can still hear the harass in
the background it doesn't stop 77 is
working for the harasser and it looks
like she's going to use her knife and
there it is just pause right there let's
back up and see that again very
difficult that's right
knifing someone back in cs:go while
they're standing still or probably have
left their computer it's one of the most
difficult moves of all time this is
supposed to stop harassment everyone
this is what their idea even if this
wasn't completely fake and staged it's
still a terrible idea see in the lower
left hand corner let's pause that and
zoom into that our bully hunter left the
calling card message to the harasser
harassment is not a game bully hunters
org we sure showed him everyone loved
the music that they added hahaha we've
been waving text from the bullies the
harassment has been taken care of this
fixes all the problems now let's see
exactly how a bully hunt works this is
our casual gamer pink light 23 who has
been harassed in game a pink like 23
what you're gonna do is you're gonna sit
here and play Counter Strike and when
the light shows at you that means you've
been harassed so be sure to maybe show
some sort of emotion you can cry if you
want to now let's see how she used our
global tool to call a bully hunter they
have an audience reacting to it do they
not understand that this illegitimate is
their whole point if their goal is to
show that harassment is real and which
I'm not denying by the way they just
create the off
that if fake now if you're not for some
reason surely this is fake
basically they even discovered that
bully hunter 77 is the same person that
was being bullied they literally just
changed the name on this team profile
which you can see by looking at them and
it's just so laughably bad it reminds me
of so many times I work with agencies
but especially back in the past where
they are just so extremely tone-deaf to
what is a good idea and what is not a
good idea because they never actually
made anything online so they don't know
how people are going to perceive these
sort of things and this is just one of
those ideas that for some reason no one
said no to steal serious which one of
the brands that was involved and when
they got call out on all of this their
response was if the only thing that
comes of this is a conversation around
the topic then we feel it is still a
step in the right direction stop we need
to I'm tired of hearing this argument if
only we did one step for women then it's
a step that is worth taking no okay you
did more harm than good here clearly
this is so idiotic that no one is going
to take harassment seriously that's how
stupid it is so don't pretend that you
took a step forward this is taking a
step back and for what selling
headphones great fantastic initiative
you got there
wait companies need to stop using
charity as some sort of ploy to seem as
good moral beings you're not you're just
morons everyone involved with this is
immoral proceeds from this will go to
support victims of harassment in gaming
what does that mean who-who who could
that possibly go to I have a victim of
harassment in gaming okay can I please
have some of the SteelSeries money I I
could really use this one of the hosts
involved the tweeted out that it was
never supposed to be taken as happening
live here's the script
oh okay so because you shared the script
that means all the sudden that
it wasn't supposed to be scripted right
oh my god I can't begin to count the
hours I've spent gaming online in that
time I have seen every imaginable sort
of harassment and threatening language
and yes I have even used some of that
language myself no no you can't play the
victim card
you're just being criticized like
everyone else can be on the Internet
we need to stop giving away pity as a
currency to these people they literally
feed off it
you're being criticized just because
some people are being rude online
doesn't make the fact that you messed up
any less okay no no one deserves to be
harassed
I'm not ignoring that that's the thing
I've seen videos of other twitch
streamers that probably would have been
more appropriate to have hosting this
event by the way yes it is a problem
this certainly doesn't fix it but
hilarious nonetheless I tell you guys
ass is coming out on Nintendo's switch I
check it out link it or skip you you
know you don't want to miss this this is
a game of the year everyone our next
story comes from Eppie Faria Twitter
user so I'm watching Peter pie on
YouTube because I'm trash no no no don't
self-deprecating right you're an
intellectual nothing less I'm greeted
with an ADD of dancing chick titled hot
girl 2018 and this thumbnail what we're
of course going to censor this there's
no way I would ever show something this
bad on my channel I want everyone that
watches my videos to feel safe at all
times so we will censor this of course I
feel like it for years now I play this
game with YouTube or everyone where it's
it's as okay so if you want mid-roll ads
you're gonna have to make the video ten
minutes that's just a rule okay fine all
right if you want any sort of decent ads
make sure or none age restriction make
sure you don't swear and use the
explicit language fine okay sure I also
make sure you don't have any explicit
content jokes or a controversial topic
okay fine
okay great here is your head it's
straight up pork thank you thank you so
much now I noticed my CPM dropping a few
weeks ago and I try to understand why
this happened that's why I especially
try to really cut down on swearing and
this sort of thing hasn't done anything
at all and then you see these ads show
show up and it's it's pretty damn
frustrating it really feels like I slap
in the face
YouTube's responded and took down this
ad very quickly which I commend him for
thank you for doing that but there was
the same thing going on last week there
was like a Vigano in one of my
thumbnails of an ad and it's just like
why how is this happening
how far is this gonna stretch how far is
this gonna go anyway next news everybody
our last news come from Jacques himself
that's right he's back he had to testify
in front of the Congress you probably
saw this because of privacy issues and
concerns and those are of course
important topics to discuss but I wanted
to focus on some other questions that
came up through this that I found a lot
more interesting enticing with what we
talked about earlier here which is
harassment or hate speech rather
Zuckerberg was asked to define hate
speech for example senator I think that
this is a really hard question and I
think it's one of the reasons why we
struggle with it I'm worried about the
psychological categories around speech
40% of Americans under age 35 tell
pollsters they think the First Amendment
is dangerous because you might use your
freedom to say something that hurts
somebody else's feelings as we as we
were able to technologically shift
especially having AI proactively look at
content I think that that's gonna create
massive questions for society about what
obligations we want to require companies
to yeah you're right suck the AI
determination of what's harmful content
has really worked out really well as
here over on YouTube but so I don't see
any problem with that
their social media platforms are not
neutral platforms but bear some
responsibility for the content I agree
that we're responsible for the content
previously it's been up in the air
whether Facebook is a neutral platform
or if they are responsible for the
content and to admit this it sort of
changed
is the whole dynamic of the thinks
obviously they're a private company
they're free to do whatever they want if
they want to censor content they are
open to do so but previously it hasn't
really been clear are you a free
platform or do you censor content or do
you shape or control what's posted on
your site and is this is same sort of
struggle that's going on here on YouTube
where whether YouTube want it to be or
not they are responsible for what's on
their website it's an interesting
question to me because now that you have
these massive companies like Google and
Facebook controlling such massive means
of communication and important means of
communication it's is it within their
right to censor that communication or do
they even have to do it are they they've
sort of forced into a corner to do it we
see a lot of ideas being censored on
YouTube and Facebook because they're not
popular with the media they have such a
massive control over what sort of ideas
are acceptable and not and that to me is
a lot scarier than this whole issue with
privacy that apparently this meeting was
all about and if this continues in the
future who knows what kind of
implications it will have that was it
for this week's pew news hope you
enjoyed this video and their many ads
that she was shown many great if you
didn't have any ads please consider
buying a mug it would really help me out
a lot a pew news Mike check out the link
in the description I am Gloria Borger
and this is me signing up
now that's what this is all about
removing harassment from gaming
harassment has no place here